[Music]
hey Sean hey Chris see that new Call of
Duty trailer I most certainly did power
changes everything bro I don't know
that's the title of it or something why
do trailers have titles because uh
they're like miniature novels each one
tells a story from start to finish and
in this case it's the story of virtual
Kevin Spacey sure is uh we're coming at
you live from the Spacey Drome yep here
uh so they showed a little bit of the
campaign stuff Spacey being like Oh
my uh you know drama drama whatever yes
it alternately looked like really good
like those soldiers running through that
hallway that part was cool super like it
was just a quick moment but it looked
super realistic and then you got spy
who's like he's still in that uncanny
valley of like his his eyes yeah not
quite there I don't know what it is it's
a it's a little offputting it's like a
like the shark from Jaws it's black eyes
like Do's eyes black eyes like a do but
you know Jau was a great movie maybe
this will be a great game who knows and
so we got The Campaign a little bit and
then they showed some multiplayer like
sizzor real like I'm going to butt stomp
a guy and then I'm going to butt stomp a
car and it's going to blow up and like
some of that stuff is cool having played
the multiplayer like I I like that stuff
that but the trailer wasn't really about
selling the fact that like you could
throw a spike ball into some dude's Dome
W it was about the co-op right exactly
it was a new co-op trailer kind of
bookended by two and a half minutes of
other footage but the co-op stuff I mean
on the surface it kind of looks like a
direct continuation of the survival kind
of horde based uh mode that Sledgehammer
did with Modern Warfare 3 Sledgehammer
collaborated on Modern Warfare 3 with
infinity W and they specifically did
that survival mode I think yeah I think
they kind of took charge on that
particular game mode so they have
experience in this and this is them kind
of like stepping forward with it and
even in the trailer you can see kind of
you know like waves of different types
of enemies you've got the vanilla
soldiers you got the jumping soldiers
you got the invisible guys you got the
heavy Mech dudes incoming uh like it's
sort you know like you're facing
different waves of different types of
enemies you're clearly earning
experience or some kind of currency or
upgrade points you can see in one of the
shots that's something that they did
with the Modern Warfare 3 survival mode
and I think to me that's kind of the
biggest question here because we've seen
a lot of the exo suit stuff we've seen a
lot of the like the really cool movement
stuff and at this point that's kind of a
known commodity like I want to know how
big is the progression system going to
going to be like how much are they going
to change that from what they did
previously do you mean within the
survival mode specifically within the
survival mode yeah cuz you've got these
soldiers all dressed up in their like
matching super soldier outfits uh but
you know like are you are you sort of
going through the the multiplayer
progression and and getting the same
kind of unlocks are they tailoring it to
the survival mode with the different uh
perks that you'll be able to get with
the different Battlefield assets you
know they show the shield they obviously
that the heavy mech suit is going to
factor in in some way um I don't know
man like it seems it's it's like a thing
to do it's not ever been mode has never
really been something that lights my
fire but yeah so they showed that off
and then it was interesting at the end
of the uh sort of clip the voiceover
said like all right like that was great
like gear up and run it again load up
and run it again I'm not sure if that
was a gear up and run the next wave or
gear up and like run the survival mode
again which would maybe indicate some
kind of overarching progression there so
I mean you know obviously the point of a
trailer it's show you some information
raise some questions as well uh but yeah
let's look at the new the new co-op
business and of course that sweet get
over here move yeah absolutely I mean it
was definitely one of those trailers
with like a lot of really cool signature
moments in it and that might just be the
best of the bunch oh my God he rips him
right out of the thing and then he's
like I'm going slam your face oh yeah
that looks pretty fun pretty fine
although definitely a highlight
definitely a highlight maybe not the
highlight of the trailer come to think
of it there might be one better moment
in there I just can't quite put my
finger on it or you know five five yeah
[Music]